odds are somewhere among the estimated
100 billion planets in our galaxy
intelligent alien life has taken hold so
the question is why haven't we found
even a hint of it while scientists could
stick with the classic reasoning that
alien life simply doesn't exist or maybe
it just doesn't exist near us mounting
evidence to the contrary has inspired an
increasing number of experts to explore
new avenues of possibility in 2017 a
team out of the University of Oxford
proposed the estivation hypothesis it's
the idea that most aliens are
hibernating sort of like a bear but for
longer
the scientists reason that just about
any advanced civilization will
eventually merge with machines forming a
fully digitized society that can think
act and function on levels beyond our
imagination the only problem with that
is cooling processing systems here on
earth for example become 10 times more
efficient when they're in an environment
that is ten times colder so digital
aliens would see the logic of
hibernating for a few trillion years or
so while the universe expands in pools
that way they can then devote more
processing power toward important
activities like conquering the galaxy
instead of simply keeping their systems
from overheating
another idea proposed in 2016 is what's
called the Gaian bottleneck hypothesis
it addresses the fact that many young
rocky planets no older than 1 billion
years have extremely unstable climates
and eventually grow too hot or too cold
for life to exist long term take Venus
Earth and Mars for example 4 billion
years ago
each planet had the right conditions for
life and may have even harbored simple
microorganisms but as far as we can tell
only life on Earth survives today the
reason according to the bottleneck
hypothesis is that early life on earth
evolved rapidly releasing large amounts
of gases like oxygen into the atmosphere
that ultimately helped stabilize the
climate but this behavior is likely the
exception than the norm so perhaps the
real reason we haven't found aliens yet
is because well they're all dead but
what if life could flourish in a
completely different environment safe
from extreme temperature fluctuations
and radiation
that's what planetary scientist Allen
Stern proposed in 2017 about a year
after evidence suggested that Pluto
harbors an underground ocean in fact
worlds like Pluto Europa and Enceladus
that have an icy shell above a vast
subterranean ocean may offer a better
incubator for life than earth-like
planets which are more vulnerable to
extreme temperature changes and
high-energy radiation that strikes the
surface if this turns out to be the case
any intelligent life that may be
swimming on these worlds would be shut
off from the rest of the universe
potentially unable to communicate
whatever the reason may be we must
answer the question of how we can
improve our search for what would be the
grandest discovery in human history
you